public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le bras droit des manuels macro et même
son guerrier c'est ainsi que l'on
présente notre invité cette semaine
richard ferrand bonsoir vous êtes le
secrétaire général désormais de la
république en marche vous suivez le
président élu depuis depuis ses débuts
depuis son engagement pour cette
présidentielle
merci donc d'être présent à ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec life
paix avec les échos et radio classique
un moment clé et même crucial 1 c cap
sur les législatives
trois grandes questions bien sûr au
cours de cette émission quelle majorité
demain entraînée par quel premier
ministre jérémy marot vous le demandera
dans un instant quelle réforme
rapidement pour répondre à la crise
sociale mais sans provoquer une levée de
boucliers des syndicats notamment qui se
mobilisent déjà question que vous posera
jean-francis pécresse enfin quel
président sera emmanuel macron la marche
du louvre donne déjà peut être une idée
mais vous en dirai plus tout à l'heure
un mickaël szames s mais d'abord une
première question d'actualité
[Musique]
manuel valls annonce donc sa candidature
aux législatives au nom de la nouvelle
majorité présidentielle il va devoir
bien sûr respecter la procédure le temps
presse puisque il doit le faire d'ici
demain mais vous vous richard ferrand
est ce que vous voyez la candidature de
manuel valls comme un atout ou comme un
poids était d'abord je crois qu'il faut
prendre cette nouvelle pour ce qu'elle
est c'est un ancien premier ministre
donc une personnalité éminente qui juge
que la démarche des manuels macro et
celle que nous poursuivons est donc la
bonne pour la france donc moi j'en
prends acte avec satisfaction ensuite
pour le reste s'il souhaite être
candidat aux législatives et
singulièrement investi par la république
en marche
eh bien il faut qu'il matérialise sa
candidature que la commission nationale
d'investiture que préside jean paul
delevoye s'en saisissent et jeudi avant
midi
vous avez le droit vous d'avoir
également un souhait un voeu est ce que
vous le souhaitez voir investie est ce
que vous me dire oui ou non
écoutez vous savez tout ça n'est pas le
fait d'une ou autre une autre
personnalité c'est un ensemble nous
avons posé des critères nous voulons
plus de 50% qui deux camps des deux
candidats guy proviennent de la société
civile respecter la parité le pluralisme
et c'est alors si la démarche de manuel
valls trouve sa place dans cet ensemble
de critères
je ne vois pas a priori d'inconvénient
merdes inconvénients mais vous y mettez
des cinémas comme si ça n'était pas
automatique vous l'avez dit un ancien
premier ministre et rien n'est
automatique moi j'ai déposé ma
candidature je ne suis pas encore
investi à l'heure qu'il est vous n'êtes
pas encore mais sur le fond manuel valls
est tout à fait macro compatit compatit
vous êtes d'accord il a appelé à voter
pour lui ils sont nombreux ceux qui ont
un peu érodé volet wii
non je crois qu'il faut il faut examiner
les motivations les termes les termes de
sa candidature voilà faire ce que l'on
fait beau tout le monde d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron dans le documentaire de
tf1 qui était diffusé hier soir que vous
avez sans doute regarder traite
manuel valls de traître un traître à
hollande responsable d'un impeachment
sans prise de risque personnel ajoutait
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron vous avez
noté la formule est ce que vous craignez
donc sur le considèrent comme un traître
à danger de manque de loyauté de sa part
demain alors que les normes et il ne
faut pas faire de procès d'intention qui
que ce soit ce ne serait pas très
bienveillant non ce que je crois si vous
voulez c'est que la la la phrase
d'emmanuel macro et pour tout vous dire
je n'ai pas eu le temps de regarder des
films en terre et je voulais rapportés
mais je le traître je vous en fils de
risques personnels
oui vous êtes est une manière de dire à
l'époque pour remettre les choses dans
leur contexte j'imagine c'est à cette
époque là que emmanuel macron avait reçu
de la part d'anciens premiers ministres
un certain nombre de leçons morales en
disant que lui-même avait trahi c'était
une démarche solitaire enfin vous vous
souvenez que une candidature
s'improviser par un certain nombre
d'amabilités liées au contexte ben et au
fond ensuite l'analyse café macron ça a
été de dire si j'en crois cette phrase
ça et c'est à dire que finalement lui il
a démissionné
emmanuel macron il a démissionné de la
fonction publique qu'il a créé son
mouvement et il a proposé de nouvelles
offres politiques aux français on avait
compris qu'il ce cycle conséquent amis
n'étaient pas dans une logique de rester
au sein de l'exécutif pour anciens que
de jouer des coudes pour être candidat
différencier c'est ce qu'il a voulu dire
effectivement dans ce commentaire
le ps est mort a dit également
aujourd'hui manuel valls il est mort
pour bosser un coup t il paraître en vie
il a il à plusieurs ça y est la mode de
candidats il
manifestement encore des gens qui
veulent mener la bagarre des
législatives qui ont déclaré une plate
forme donc ceux qui résistent à la
tentation macro en tout cas il n'est pas
en grande forme il n'est pas mort
beaucoup témoin je n'aime pas comme ça
proclamait des actes de décès alors je
préfère voir la république en marche
avec megan intéresse plus le ps est mort
pour vous personnellement vous avez
rendu votre quart pour les déchirer ou
ça y est non je dis que 20 vu le niveau
de responsabilité qui étaient les
miennes
il était logique que je n'adhère plus au
parti socialiste mais elles sont en body
trompette d'accord donc vous n'est plus
membre évidemment du parti soucier de
piquant précisément quelques jours
depuis quelques jours la voilà si je
vais prendre le temps je n'ai pas eu
beaucoup de rencontrer avant
d'officialiser les choses
celles et ceux avec qui depuis bien
longtemps je milite et qui sont devenus
en bretagne et singulièrement dans le
finistère
mes amis et qui sauf qu'il faut compter
à nouveau évidemment dans les semaines
qui viennent non seulement ça mais ce
sont des amis donc quand on a des amis
on leur explique ce qu'on fait ils ont
compris depuis un moment à vous
concernant certains enfin la suite avec
jérémy marot de la fp qui nous rejoint
donc et on va rester sur la question des
législatives
l'épreuve de vérité avec life fait
bonsoir jérémy sont michel bonsoir
monsieur ferrand alors je dis vous
présenterez jeudi avant-midi vous
présenterez les 577 candidats qui
doivent composer la majorité
présidentielle leur part est il qu'ils
aient eu énormément de coups de fil de
dernière minute des parlementaires des
députés qui soudainement se disent ah
tiens il faudrait que j'en vois un
formulaire en marche
c'est exact là monsieur gros sur viens
de parler du plus célèbre d'entre eux
mais il est vrai que il y a des
vocations tardives qui s'éveille et
qu'est ce que vous leur dites à ces
vocations tardives où il est ce que j'ai
répondu à monsieur grossiord c il était
temps il va falloir variés ou à la
commission d'investiture va s'en saisir
et puis on vous dira ce qu'on pense et
parmi eux il ya beaucoup il y aura des
déçus forcément vous savez il y a un peu
plus de 15000 ce que c'est pas moi qui
suit c'est directement mais enfin plus
de 15000 candidates et candidats mais
qui savent bien entendu que seuls 577
c'est le nombre de circonscriptions
seront retenus donc les régles du jeu
sont claires depuis le début que cela
passe par une commission nationale
d'investiture c'est connu les critères
sont tenus donc il n'y aura pas de
surprises en tout cas peut-être y
aura-t-il des déçus parce que quand on
candidate à quelque chose et qu'on n'ait
pas retenu c'est la vie à tous une
pointe de déception
bon mais cela étant les choses auront
été fait dans la transparence dans les
règles et sous l'autorité de jean paul
delevoye est plus plus sérieusement vous
sentez un petit vin chaud sérieux vous
serez un petit vent de panique non quand
même à gauche on se dit là il est temps
de voir rejoindre c'est la dernière
chance dernier wagon
oui mais nous on ne lit pas comme ça si
vous les noms nous voulons vous savez il
faut pas oublier une chose en marche
repose sur deux jambes en marche sur
deux jambes
le rassemblement et le renouvellement et
moi je suis garant que ces deux
promesses soient tenues
le rassemblement ça veut dire à la fois
des citoyens engagés dans différentes
sensibilités et qui se retrouve dans le
projet porté par emmanuel macron et le
renouvellement
cela veut dire
que des personnes qui avaient jusque-là
des mandats locaux ou pas demander du
tout doit venir s'investir dans la vie
politique et donc je suis comme
secrétaire général le garant de ces deux
promesses mondariz religieusement et je
puis vous dire que même seront tenus est
ce que les électeurs auront le temps de
prendre en fait connaissance de la
dimension personnelle de ses candidats
venus de la société civile des inconnus
que vous dites est ce que c'est pas un
risque là que vous courrez dans ses
vocalises et même si elles manuel macron
sur la fiche
évidemment en gros oui c'est vous qui
dites que ce sont des inconnus mais vous
savez pour la plupart ce sont des gens
qui font campagne depuis le 16 novembre
pour emmanuel macron qui dans chaque
chef-lieu de canton dans les communes de
leur territoire rione emportant le
projet la candidature d'emmanuel magron
ce ne sont pas des gens sorti d'un
chapeau
par conséquent la population a déjà
repéré que madame untel monsieur untel
ou autres sont les engagés pour la
candidature d'emmanuel macron donc après
on dirat bahri ben non ils sont investis
un chaos former la majorité
alors vous le mouvement marche plein
depuis sa création pour la transparence
peut être qu'il est temps de vous dire
combien de cire construction sont
réservés aux au modem finalement alors
vous pourrez le détectée jeudi avant
midi
mais en vérité on veut pas rentrer dans
cette idée qu'il y aurait une pesée au
trébuchet ce n'est pas sale état
d'esprit l'état d'esprit pourquoi y at
il eu avec le modem est qu'avec le modem
un accord de cette nature c'est parce
que monsieur bayrou avait la capacité la
légitimité l'histoire pour être candidat
à la présidence de la république
il a donc proposé de renoncer à sa
candidature au bénéfice d'une alliance
en disant qu'il souhaitait que cette
alliance se fasse à la fois dans un
souci de représentativité de sa
sensibilité et dans l'indépendance du
mouvement en marche que emmanuel macron
a créé bon voilà les conditions de
l'accord et ce qui a été dit en même
temps par nous et par lui c'est que nous
voulons sacrifier aucun talent émergent
aucune candidature nouvelles sous
prétexte que la personne ne serait pas
modem pur sucre si je puis dire
donc les choses doivent se faire en
bonne intelligence pour que les
meilleures candidates et les meilleurs
candidats par consensus émerge et porte
toute la bannière la république en
marche
donc les choses se font en bonne
intelligence et jeudi il sera temps de
constater les termes de l'accord de
celles et ceux qui voudront figuré
ensuite dans ou modèles et notamment
voir également ceux qui viennent de la
droite un accent de gâcher l'effet de
surprise dit nous est ce que je dis on
verra des députés de droite ou venant de
la droite dans les 577 nom que vous
présidez députés actuellement sortant
voilà vous écouter il se peut qu'il y en
a quelques-uns oui comme il y aura
quelques députés socialistes si pour
l'instant vous voyez que du coup l'effet
de renouvellement sera beaucoup plus
ample que le sait que nous avons fixés
car ils ne sont pas si nombreux
finalement pour l'instant voilà il n'y
avait qu'un parlementaire qui vous a
officiellement rejoint ce le sénateur
jean baptiste lemoyne mais aucun député
expliquez-nous quels sont les freins
mais parmi nos candidats vous trouverez
des élus locaux qui qui sont le
sensibilité dorotte ça vous mais
pourquoi les députés de droite et si
vous ne connaissez pas ou on voulait
montrera parce que vous comprenez il ya
un truc que je trouve étrange depuis la
création du mouvement en marche on me
dit je vais enfin quels sont vos
soutiens parlementaires comme si la vie
politique en france se faisait selon le
nombre de parlementaires qui soutiennent
pierre ou paul
je ne crois pas regarder benoît hamon
avait beaucoup de parlementaires qui
l'avaient soutenu monsieur mélenchon
avait beaucoup moins monsieur macro
encore moins bon vous connaissez les
résultats
donc si vous voulez nous j'essaye depuis
plus d'un an d'expliquer que ce n'est
pas ça l'essentiel
d'accord mais l'essentiel pour vous
c'est de décrocher la majorité absolue
est ce que vous êtes convaincus de
l'obtenir
sachant que les observateurs considèrent
que ce serait de la part du président
élu un nouvel exploit une nouvelle
mission impossible
est ce que vous êtes toujours convaincu
oui oui oui je suis convaincu que nous
sommes capables je ne vous dis pas que
nous allons réussir
c'est comme quand emmanuel macron était
candidat je disais
je j'ai la conviction que nous avons la
capacité d'y arriver mais on verra quoi
ce sont quand même les électrices et les
électeurs qui décident
on verra merci beaucoup jérémy la suite
de l'épreuve de vérité vêtements avec
jean francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique qui nous
rejoint par francis michel bonsoir
richard ferrand soir alors qu'elle
grandes réformes sociales
faut-il attendre dans les 100 jours
d'abord vous savez moi je partage l'idée
avec emmanuel macron que cette date des
100 jours période est 100 jours c'est
une date funeste dans l'histoire de
france que s'est mal terminée et pour
que par ailleurs cinq ans et passe en
jour mais enfin je comprends pas on
commence il a réfuté et puis après il a
dit que quand même ça avait un sens de
faire de faire assez vite des réformes
que l'on ne fait pas plus tard surtout
quand elles sont impopulaires au coeur
de l'été préférant par exemple
maintenant nous allons mener une
campagne électorale dans la clarté donc
si nous avons une majorité parce que
nous portons nos réformes c'est pas
qu'ils seront impopulaires c'est que
nous aurons réussi à faire comprendre
qu'elles sont utiles au pays ont fait
pas des réformes pour être impopulaires
ou pour embêter le monde
en effet parce qu'on a la conviction
qu'elles vont servir le pays alors pour
répondre à votre question chantier
numéro un c'est la moralisation de la
vie publique
ça c'est avant les législatives qu'il
faudra examiner par examiner faire
adopter ou débattre en conseil des
ministres du gouvernement
c'est le premier texte qui doit venir
c'est un engagement emmanuel macron des
la majorité élue à l'assemblée nationale
manuel macron souhaite que le premier
chantier soit celui de la simplification
du code du travail du droit du travail
et le troisième chantier qui va venir
avant l'été ce sera évidemment de
préparer la rentrée scolaire selon les
règles que nous avons définies notamment
que pour dans les quartiers où on
constate qu'il ya beaucoup d'enfants un
échec on puisse avoir peu plus de douze
enfants devra mettre une maîtresse et
pendant l'été il s'agira de préparer le
budget 2010 8 le premier budget utile du
quinquennat qui intégrera les
différentes réformes fiscales sur
l'impôt sur les sociétés l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes tels que le candidat
désormais lui a eu l'occasion d'écrire
sur la le calendrier sur l'année comment
est-ce que vous réagissez aux
manifestations qui ont eu lieu hier à
paris au lendemain de l'élection du
président de la république et qui se
veulent un avertissement sociale
l'avertissement est également celui de
jean luc mélenchon vous allez répondre
dans un instant mais je vais également
vous faire écouter tout de suite eric
coquerel des vins sont mises sur le même
thème effectivement qu'aborde
jean-francis la politique qu'il a
annoncé faut pas l'oublier
hier tout ça a été encore une fois un
enrobage pour paquets cadeaux la
plitique il annoncé c'est toujours plus
de dérégulation du super lourd travail
il va s'en prendre aux retraites
il a annoncé à l'as vence 60 milliards
de plus d'austérité aux essais cette
politique là qu'il va bien falloir à un
moment donné qu'il présente aux
législatives
or depuis hier ce que nous savons c'est
que plus de la majorer plus de la moitié
des français
bien que la moitié français n'ont pas
voté pour lui et danseuse dans dans son
électorat à peu près la bâtisse sur
lectorat sont les études au vote et
polypes faire barrage au front national
donc oui à des appels à l on entend la
résistance et il ya quelque chose qui me
gêne beaucoup dans il ya une chose qui
m'étonne et de choses qui me qu'imagine
chose qui m'étonne c'est que monsieur
que crème n'est pas annoncer
l'apocalypse parce que quand on l'entend
on a l'impression que véritablement il y
aurait des politiques cachées autres pas
du tout je voudrais ensuite dire que
nous avons distribué 50 millions de
tracts plus les professions de foi que
nous vous et moi avons reçu dans nos
boîtes aux lettres et à aucun moment ses
intentions que nous avons sur ce
terrain-là mans était dissimulée et
ensuite ce que je trouve très choquant
et qui te on frôle le propos factieux
c'est ce procès année légitimité qui
serait fait à l'élection du président
macron est grosso modo en dix ans donc
ok on a voté pour lui parce que le pen 2
était dangereuse mais par conséquent
nous sommes fondés à nous opposer à tout
je crois ensuite que cette manie mieux
de vous non je vous ai dit que ces
propos qui étaient à la limite de propos
factieux je crois qu'il faut reconnaître
le résultat des élections va commencer
par ça laissez le gouvernement
s'installe et le dialogue social se
dérouler et ensuite il y aura bien sûr
je bien entendu monsieur coquerelles et
d'autres qui continueront à raconter
linverse ce que nous faisons en vrai et
qui vont essayer de mal expliqué ce que
nous faisons ce que c'est pas leur rôle
ce sera le nôtre donc à nous de faire ce
travail mais vous voyez bien quand même
qui a un sentiment particulier au
lendemain de cette élection
présidentielle on a le sentiment qu'ils
aiment qu'il n'y aura pas un état de
grâce comme en général il ya petite
période et adra cela m'a l'impression
qu'il ya pas d'état de grâce
c'est ce que dit laurent berger jusqu'au
10 leur enverra un courrier le patron de
la cfdt le dit oui mais bon je vous
expliquer comment je le ressens c'est
maigre santé aussi
c'est à dire que les françaises et les
français
clairement estime qu'il faut tourner la
page
d'ailleurs c'est ce que nous leur avons
proposé avec le quinquennat qui s'achève
et même avec 20 ans de pratique que
institutionnels et de politiques qui
n'ont pas réussi donc il y à une
impatience et il y a même chez emmanuel
macron une impatience à agir donc tout
le monde envie d'agir et de mettre en
oeuvre le programme qui est le nôtre
ceci explique sans doute qu' il n'y ait
pas ce sentiment
ça a été trop grasse déjà c'est un
concept théologique de françois
mitterrand avait appliqué à la vie
politique c'est un moment de de joie
collective de flottement où tout le
monde est heureux dire ensemble on a
très bien compris que l'acuité l'urgence
des problèmes là multiplient la
multiplicité des sujets auxquels il faut
donner des réponses quasiment en même
temps fait qu'il ya une impatience et
pas du tout deux situations de béatitude
collective si vous voulez où on attend
que les choses se fassent merci beaucoup
jean-francis voit la dernière partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
michaël szames est ce qui nous rejoint
maintenant
[Musique]
bonsoir je veux savoir quel président
sera emmanuel macron on a vu une image
peut-être pouvoir la découvrir ensemble
l'image du louvre il a été doublement
regardant la marche solitaire évidemment
sur l'esplanade du musée avec la
pyramide dans laxe de la tête du
président élu pour son qu'est ce qu'elle
vous deviez dire de la soirée que vous
inspire cette image quand vous l'avez
découvert vous étiez sur place j'imagine
est-ce que c'était ce côté mitterrandien
où c'était totalement l'opposé d'un
françois hollande à nicolas sarkozy
d'abord c'est un marcheur je l'avais
observé mais au-delà de ce commentaire
je crois que c'est une certaine
solennité qui correspondait à au
sentiment de joie empreinte de gravité
qui était ce que ressentaient emmanuel
macron c'est à dire qu emmanuel macron a
évidemment pris la mesure que les
françaises et les français ont mis
finalement beaucoup d'espoirs en lui et
en tout cas n'ont pas hésité quand on
vise les contradicteurs n'ont pas hésité
à évacuer ceux qui incarnait une
certaine manière de faire de la
politique
donc il sent bien il sent bien que il a
sur lui une promesse mais une promesse
fondatrice à tenir qui est de rassembler
les françaises et les français
d'ailleurs il a dit combien elle était
conscient que madame le pen malgré ce
débat où elle a montré tant de haine et
en incompétence
elle a quand même réussi à obtenir trois
plus un peu plus du tiers des voix donc
c'est quand même un souci que la par
ailleurs par exemple un impressionnant
c'est un président rassembleur
ils avaient plaisir de bérulle donc bon
4 millions il faut il faut en prendre
compte richard ferland tenir comprendre
un président jupiter ya c'était manuel
macro qui s'est décrit lui-même comme
cela dans la presse
ça veut dire quoi selon un président qui
tranche qui prend les grandes décisions
se comme ça que je le produirait donc ça
veut dire aussi les tranches aussi par
rapport à ses prédécesseurs et c'est ce
que voulait dire en tout cas lui là vous
dire comment elle se réduit
je vous laisse le soin de comparer leur
est ce que ça veut dire par exemple
qu'il va avoir beaucoup de distance par
rapport à la presse notamment par
rapport à sa phase
d'autres voir cette présidence en gros
esquive à l'elysée on le voit plus les
français le verrons le journaliste peut
être moins qu'avant puisque tout de même
vous savez il faut bien prendre un peu
de recul mais enfin vous êtes plus
qualifiés que moi pour le faire mais en
dix ans sur les quinquennat de messieurs
sarkozy hollande qui doivent correspond
à peu près à l'émergence des chaînes
d'information et ses alliés ne peut plus
passer un événement sans que présente la
république et sont moins dire du moins
juste il le dire sont bons une espèce
d'ovni présence médiatique et qui
parfois assez peu signifiantes et donc à
partir de là le sens se perd la capacité
du chef de l'exécutif a donné les
grandes perspectives de son action ces
mousses et ça ça nuit et je crois qu'ils
manuel macron a le souci lui de donner
le sens d'expliquer les grands choix
qu'il fait mais qu'ensuite qu'il y aura
un gouvernement en somme vous fera mais
la présidence sarkozy de la présidence
selon il faut faire tous la version que
je sais pas si ça suffira en tout cas
faut faire dans les deux cas parce
qu'ils étaient faits en tous les cas de
la diète médiatique est ce que il n'y a
pas eu un paradoxe étonnant en 48 heures
puisque effectivement vous souligné
qu'il y avait eu cette marche solennelle
un du président tout juste élu mais le
lendemain la retrouver lui mais sous
l'arc de triomphe avec un françois
hollande qui la traitait un peu quand
même comme un élève quoi vais pas
trouver avec ses gestes d'affection est
ce que vous avez été agacé vous
personnellement oui baron j'ai trouvé
que le président landes était
bienveillant
voilà dix ans nous positif c'était
positif et même quand le chef de l'état
actuel encore quelques jours indique
qu'il a indiqué la marche à suivre à
emmanuel macron seuil et ils ont envie
je ne pense pas que c'est bouleversé les
françaises n'ont pas non plus prononcé
une phrase vous avez pas vu le
documentaire ou ce qu'on vous a parlé
que michel tout à l'heure il ya une
phrase quand même qui fait écho encore
aujourd'hui il dit si vous écoutez les
mecs de la sécurité je le cite vous
finissez comme hollande
vous êtes mort oui est ce qu il a raison
pas bien sûr parce que emmanuel macron
ne souhaite pas être un président en
serré
enfermé dans le palais de l'elysée
d'ailleurs vous le voyez bien dans ses
déplacements de ministres et même deux
candidats et parfois ça donne des images
qui n'ont pas toujours à son avantage
mais il aime aller au contact
voilà quand il des pratiques communes de
l'économie s'il y avait un piquet de
grève ou des gens qui manifestaient il
aller au contact
il va discuter il aime le contact direct
il aime la confrontation et surtout plus
que la confrontation la pédagogie
égouttez le ressenti des uns et des
autres s'entendre dire ce qui à leurs
yeux de aux yeux de nos concitoyens ne
va pas et leur apporter des réponses en
prendre note et c'est ce ne sera pas un
président médiatique ce serait un
président à l'écouté et à l'action il ya
encore des jeux dont on a besoin de
savoir sur cette personnalité ce
président qu'il sera une biographie qui
sort dans les prochains jours de nos
confrères françois-xavier bourmaud du
figaro il décrit aussi comme quelqu'un
qui a un côté très dur c'est quelqu'un
comme ça c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a
pas vu ou qu'on voit peu est-ce que vous
qui connaissez bien il a ce côté dur oui
oui c'est un homme très exigeant avec
lui-même et avec tous les autres
surtout lorsqu'il mesure que c'est pour
servir notre pays qu'il ya tout de même
un certain nombre de préoccupations
importantes et par conséquent oui il
sait être il sait être dur contre il
faut être dur mais n'oubliez jamais ça
dur avec lui-même
oui et avec celles et ceux qui veulent
servir le pays donc par exemple quand il
dit où on laisse dire en tout cas dans
la presse qu'il a déjà prévenu des hauts
fonctionnaires près de 250
fonctionnaires des hauts fonctionnaires
et bien évidemment qu'ils ne seraient
pas sur la même ligne que lui
hop on fait ménage non attention il n'a
pas dit ça comme ça il a dit simplement
que les hauts fonctionnaires qui sont
légitimement occuper leurs positions
doivent développer la culture du
résultat c'est à dire que quand un
ministre dira recevra les instructions
du premier ministre
pour dire voilà les objectifs atteindre
voilà à quelles dates doit sortir les
décrets les arrêtés de telles lois etc
etc
si les choses se passent mal le ministre
pourra pas cet exemple c'est un exemple
ce n'est pas une règle mais le ministre
pourra être révoqué tout comme un
directeur de l'administration pour être
révoqués de chasse aux sorcières n'ont
pas de chasse aux sorcières mais la
culture du résultat pas a priori je dis
rien il n'est en train d'instaurer où il
ne va pas estoril reims poésie ce cas là
on 16
bien sûr que non qu'avait d'ailleurs
imaginer nicolas sarkozy mais je vais
vous donner deux exemples
il ya quelque chose ou un titre d'élu
local car c'est shawn est du territoire
moi qui m'ont qui m'ont toujours choquée
vous avez vous rappeler comment jean
yves le drian avait des difficultés sur
le logiciel ou voile au sujet de cela
dans le pays et dvd me libérant milite
les soldes des militaires et la vie
voyez vous voyez dans quel bourbier
nous sommes aujourd'hui au ministère de
l'agriculture s'agissant de payer les
primes pac ya à peu près deux ans de
retard alors le ministère et le ministre
le foll s'est débattue dans cette
difficulté fait des avances régulière
pour que les agriculteurs puissent
toucher à vous pouvez 80% est repris et
on me dit que ce système informatique a
coûté plusieurs dizaines de millions
mais non d'une pipe je me dis mais y
at-il eu des sanctions
bah c'est ça que je vais vous donner
comme exemple des sanctions auprès des
personnes qui ont un moment donné juger
et donc mal jugé sur un choix
technologique qui s'avère coûteux
ruineux défaillant et nefic temps sous
la présidence de manuel valls fonctions
ben c'est ce qu'on attendait le rapport
annuel de la cour des comptes parce que
des exemples comme ça vous en avez je
prends cela parce que moi dans mon
finistère agriculteurs m'en parle me
disent mais comment se fait-il que
parfois les primes pac de 2015 ne soit
pas soldés c'est incompréhensible si
vous me prenez trois ans de retard pour
payer vos impôts ça va pas se passer
comme ça donc s'ils voulaient à un
moment donné il faut qu'on comprenne
pourquoi il ya des dysfonctionnements et
pourquoi les mauvaises décisions ont été
prises il faut sanctionne culture du
résultat chère fait rage ces cinq jours
à venir c'est la journée de l'europe
on doit aller voir angela merkel la
semaine prochaine je sais que vous
parlez couramment allemand je vous ai vu
donner des interviews en allemand qu'est
ce qu'il doit dire
emmanuel macron gay l'américain ben que
enfin d'abord il ira ce qu'il voudra je
peux me permettre moi de lui dire ce
qu'il a à dire mes enfants
fondamentalement notre conviction c'est
quoi c'est que il va falloir urgemment
refonder l'europe que il faut que le
moteur franco-allemand se rallument pour
redonner ce souffle à l'europe
vous voyez bien que aujourd'hui alors
même que l'europe est extrêmement utile
dans de très nombreux domaines et bien
la perception que nos concitoyens à nom
est négative
donc il va bien falloir à un moment
donné que l'europe se remette à avancer
quitte à ce que cela se fasse par
cercles concentriques si je puis dire
est que ceux qui veulent pas bouger
n'empêche pas ceux qui veulent avancer
d'avancé dernière question d'actualité
marion maréchal annonce qu'elle va
quitter tous ses mandats ne va pas se
représenter à la députation dans le
vaucluse elle quitte la région paca
peut-être une forme de lassitude
on ne sait pas donc il n'y aura pas de
succession chez les le pen apparemment
comme on avait pu imaginer entre la
tante et la nièce une réaction ça vous
inspire quoi
une peine qui arrêtent de faire de la
politique moi ça ne me fâche pas puisque
si vous voulez on avait une dynastie
familiale qui depuis 40 ans était
présente à l'élection présidentielle
donc vouloir le renouvellement c'est
aussi faire en sorte qu'on n'ait pas une
pme de l'extrême droite qui prospèrent
trop voilà donc une bonne nouvelle pour
vous merci richard ferrand merci à vous
d'avoir été avec nous donc on va suivre
votre itinéraire personnel où est ce
qu'on va vous retrouver dans quelques
jours
bientôt en campagne dans le finistère
dans le finistère et peut-être également
à paris quelque part merci beaucoup en
tous les cas un devenu aujourd'hui merci
michael bonsoir à tous à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]